foreign
[Music]
the number of people killed in an
earthquake in Morocco on Friday has
risen to nearly 2 900. many survivors
have spent another night in tents after
their homes were destroyed rescue teams
continue searching for those who could
be trapped under the rubble the Army and
Aid agencies have reached some remote
villages in the Atlas Mountains
well Nicholas hark is live from we're
gone South of Marrakech and it's been
four days now since the earthquake can
you just give us a sense of what it is
like there is there a growing
frustration or anger at the lack of Aid
getting through to some of these hardest
hit areas
well look Tom we're 20 kilometers away
from the epicenter that's just behind
those steep mountains behind me now you
said in in your intro that some Villages
were accessed but many many villages are
have not received any Aid and we've seen
helicopters chin up helicopters and
other helicopters going back and forth
above these mountains to try to survey
the situation this is very much an
unfolding crisis for the Moroccan
authorities that need all the help that
they can get the qataris actually were
able to go in in some of these areas and
try to access and save some lives in the
village of safag
160 villagers were found dead flattened
by the earthquake and just earlier this
morning in Marrakesh and here there was
another Tremor 10 kilometers below
ground and people rushed outside of
their homes
this is very much a situation where
people are fearful and anxious about
what will happen next and that's why
people have set up tense
away from the steep hills this is for
them a safe place to stay at least for
now
Tom Nick you described this as an
unfolding crisis getting out into the
worst affected areas I mean it must be
hugely frustrating for for many of the
people there where is that frustration
directed at at this point in time
well look here in this area I mean a lot
of people are relying on each other to
make things happen let me just show you
around in this area where people have
set up tents and they're right now
children are working to set up tents not
Aid agencies not government officials
but families gather together survivors
helping each other in Marrakesh I sense
that there was greater frustration
towards the authorities there outside
the Medina we saw so many families
huddled around
um waiting for the authorities to help
them now there's a makeshift Camp over
there in Marrakesh here very little Aid
we've seen mostly the Moroccan Services
operating their search and rescue
mission like you see right above us a
helicopter again flying back and forth
at Chinook flying back they're trying to
get
to access those remote areas this is
still what is happening here in this
specific place but when you speak to the
villagers here and I've spoken to some
of the elders here I asked them are you
scared to stay here they say they want
to stay here they want help to rebuild
their homes to access their homes
they're unwilling to move from where
they are but we're just a month away
from the uh the cold season during the
night time the temperatures drop or
close to zero zero degrees Celsius on
Thursday there's rain expected here and
people fear what how they're going to be
able to live in the coming days is this
going to be a temporary shelter or is
this more of a permanent situation for
them
okay thank you so much for that that's
Nicholas Hawk for us